Fourteen years is a long time to wait, but
Pixar and writer/director Brad Bird have finally
brought audiences back to the comic book-inspired
world of The Incredibles.
Like any good sequel, it doesn't tie up all
of its plot threads neatly at the end of its
runtime.
There's no telling for sure if or when we'll
get a follow-up, so let's take a look at the
most pressing unanswered questions in Incredibles
2.
Where's the Underminer?
Incredibles 2 picks up exactly where the first
movie left off 14 years prior, with the Parr
family facing off against the Underminer.
"Behold, the Underminer!"
The battle rages underground and spills into
the streets as the heroes manage to just barely
save City Hall.
When the dust settles, however, the villain
has escaped, and the Incredibles' failure
to apprehend him kickstarts the rest of the
plot.
So, where has this nemesis vanished to?
The only reference the movie makes to his
whereabouts comes during the credits, when
the silhouette of his drill vehicle can be
seen driving off into the proverbial sunset.
More pressingly, what is he going to buy with
his newly acquired millions?
What was Evelyn's endgame?
Evelyn Deavor reveals her motivation to Elastigirl
in exactly the kind of supervillain monologue
that the first Incredibles film mocked.
"And When I unleash it- You sly dog!
You got me monologuing!
I can't believe it."
She blames superheroes for the death of her
father, who relied on the vigilantes even
after they were outlawed.
Manipulating her brother's sense of nostalgia,
she intends to frame supers for a terrible
attack and ensure they remain illegal forever.
After hypnotizing an entire luxury yacht full
of heroes and world leaders, Evelyn escapes
by plane while the boat steers itself towards
New Urbem.
While the rest of the assembled supers seize
control of the boat, Elastigirl narrowly thwarts
Evelyn's flight.
But if she hadn't, what would the villain
have done?
Go into hiding?
Change her name?
We may never know.
What's next for the supers?
Incredibles 2 introduces a large cast of never-before-seen
superheroes brought out of hiding by Winston
Deavor as part of his PR campaign.
Their scenes rank among the movie's highlights.
The real question is: what will they do next?
Will Voyd get to spend more time with her
idol, Elastigirl?
Will Krushauer ever truly un-crush anything?
Whatever the future holds for each of them,
their chemistry makes it nice to imagine that
they might form a team and continue working
together.
Maybe they'll lay the foundations for some
sort of avenging league of justice.
What will Jack-Jack's power be?
Speaking of intriguing superpower combinations,
it's impossible to discuss Incredibles 2 without
bringing up Jack-Jack, whose array of unpredictable
abilities provides many of the movie's most
memorable scenes.
When Bob Parr brings his infant son to Edna
Mode to ask for help, she reminds him that
many supers manifest multiple powers early
in life before growing into their defining
characteristics.
Jack-Jack, however, has many more powers than
usual for his age, and shows no sign of settling
into any one of them by the story's end.
He remains blessed with laser vision, flammability,
multiplicity, dimension-hopping, and a rage-triggered
beast mode.
The only question is what's next for the combustible
baby?
"Combustion imminent?
What does that mean?"
"It means fire, Robert."
What's Honey like?
The biggest missed opportunity in Incredibles
2 might be the choice to leave Honey Best,
better known as the wife of Frozone, off-screen
once again.
The character became an instant fan favorite
in 2004 without even showing her face as she
refuses to tell Frozone where she put his
supersuit.
"You tell me where my suit is woman!
We are talking about the greater good!"
"Greater good?
I am your wife!
I am the greatest good you are ever gonna
get!"
The sequel spends more time with the personal
life of the Parr family, and their friendship
with "Uncle Lucius" gets more screen time
as well.
But Honey is once again relegated to a cameo
in voice only as she shouts from across the
apartment.
"Suit up.
It might get weird."
"I'll be there.
ASAP."
"Where you going ASAP?
You better be back ASAP."
How long until the next sequel?
Incredibles 2 throws its audience right back
into the final scene of a movie from nearly
a decade and a half before.
The gap is so remarkable that Pixar prepared
a special introduction with the cast and crew
apologizing for the wait.
So, with all these lingering questions about
the Incredibles universe still hanging in
the air, we have to ask just one more: will
a third Incredibles ever materialize, and
when?
Considering how long the second film's fate
remained uncertain, the future of the franchise
is just as unclear as ever.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!